There's another piece to URLs I'd like to show you. And this is
the, this is the final piece I'll talk about right now, and that's
called the port. When you make a web request to a server, this
is the host, this is the, the name of the machine or, or
the location of the machine you're requesting. In order to make an internet
connection you need two things. You need one, the address of the machine,
which is represented by the host And two, you also need a port.
And by default the port equals 80. If you want to use a different port
you can include it in the URL between the
host and the path separated by a colon. And in
this case we'll be making our request on port
8,000. Get used to this URL because this will be
your local development URL for a lot of this
course, and actually for a lot of your career as
a web developer. You're constantly accessing your local machine and
you're probably doing it on something other than port 80.
There are even more parts to a URL, but they're not particularly relevant to
us right now, they'll come up, you know, as we go. Let's do one
final quiz about URL's before we move on. What I'd like you to do
is take this URL and identify its
main parts host, protocol, fragment, query, and port.